well I'm in Love The Simple Pleasures in
life like enjoying a sip of water
breathing or simply taking a leak are
just some of the sacrifices actors make
to bring us our favorite movies check
out the crazy things actors will put up
with in order to get the shot number one
cat Prosthetics like cats are evil you
may be surprised to find out that kitty
cat poly juice transformation Hermione
went through in Harry Potter wasn't CGI
and it wasn't even Emma Watson either
turns out Emma had a horrible allergic
reaction to the glue they were using on
her face so stunt double flick miles
filled in for the scene the shot isn't
entirely without CGI though as the cat
eyes were created in post maybe the
movie Cats could take a lesson or two
from Harry Potter in feline makeup
number two as opposed to
non-acts instant danger Brett Beatty was
more than just a stunt double for Reese
Davies in Lord of the Rings things
because as it turns out the actor was
allergic to his Prosthetics and this one
time bidi had to throw an ax he
accidentally nicked his eyebrow now
here's the freaky part because he was
wearing a prosthetic mask the blood
couldn't get out and actually started
building up under the mask and
eventually one of the eye bags which was
glued on ruptured and the blood started
spurting out despite how horrific the
whole event sounds apparently it looked
a lot worse than it was number three
stellen Skarsgard found himself in a bit
of a sticky situation while filming Dune
I did not want to drown in that black
goo that I was was dipping into there
his suit weighed about 88 pounds which
by the way is the weight of a baby
hippopotamus the exact look the director
was going for Skarsgard needed a cooling
vest hooked up inside the suit so he
wouldn't have a stroke and then they
found the man was too buoyant for the
oil and they had to stab holes in the
suit so he would sink number therefore
just 10 minutes of yoga and you'll be
fine we've all been there curled up in
weird positions on our computer chair
watching YouTube videos for hours on end
and waking up with a crook in the neck
in the morning Salma Hayek experienced
something similar while filming eternals
apparently it gets tiring carrying all
that extra weight around on your head
who would have thought she's not one for
complaining though and she did love the
experience number five didn't anybody
teach Johnny Depp not to run with
scissors the suit he was wearing was
supposedly so hot and tight it actually
caused him to pass out from running
while there are lots of stories about
actors coming close to passing out this
is the first we've heard of it actually
happening he didn't tell anyone he was
experiencing any dizziness ahead of time
or we're sure they would have been there
with water number six do beasts sweat or
do they pant Dan Stevens who played the
beast in the live-action Beauty and the
Beast had to use stilts and wear a
muscle vest he also needed to wear a
cooling bath to keep him from
overheating and honestly the best part
of this story is the fact he had to eat
four whole roast dinners a day to stop
himself from wasting away funny this
reminds us of one of the songs from the
movies when I was a lad I ate four whole
roast dinners the craft table on that
set must have been amazing number seven
and we don't mean the A-list actors
turns out Christian Bale could barely
breathe in his costume because when it
was cold the material would get tight on
his head it got so difficult to breathe
he recounts seeing stars and they all
had a thing or two to say to Robert
Pattinson who's taking up the character
in 2022 telling him just make sure
you're going to be able to relieve
yourself honestly that's good advice Tom
Holland had the same struggle why is
nobody building a secret zipper into
these things number eight Ruby Rose has
a bit more than Rosy Cheeks after her
time in The Mask she had a latex allergy
that only got worse throughout filming
her hives got so bad she decided not to
return for a second season poor Ruby all
she had to say was eventually I took off
the cowl at the end and my whole face
was hives my throat was all messed up it
was like it was out of a scary movie
maybe they could have recast her as the
polka dot man's sister or something
number nine listen to your mother's
advice after months of wearing caked on
makeup and heavy Prosthetics Jessica
Chastain found her skin stretched out
and feared she'd done permanent damage
to it when she finally took all that
makeup off and truly saw herself for the
first time she said she recounts looking
50 years old for the record she's 44
years old right now if you keep making
that face long enough we guess it really
does get stuck like that hopefully after
a few weeks it bounced back number 10.
maybe in this case do let go in a weird
twist of fate Kate Winslet almost
drowned while filming the Titanic she
remembers running away from a wave that
crashed against a closed gate her coat
was snagged and she suddenly found
herself submerged in water and she had
to struggle to get herself free all we
can picture now is Jack saying
from Atop The Floating door you're
welcome to steal this great fanfic idea
by the way number 11. we're pretty sure
that isn't how you kill a zombie the
life of an actor sounds glamorous in
theory but when you've got a 1am makeup
call for a 6 a.m start it seems a little
less ideal Army of the Dead's Richard
Citron found himself in this situation
when he was playing Zeus the zombie King
early mornings long days in a silicone
costume that didn't breathe filming in
Albuquerque in 100 degree weather now we
can see what taika waititi was on about
in free guy Albuquerque boiled turkey
staying hydrated is important to say the
least number 12. surprisingly the cause
isn't your annoying little brother for
getting wrapped at 4 11 and I don't mean
wrapped like goodbye for the day this is
us star Mandy Moore had to deal with
different Prosthetics depending on what
age she was playing in the show when she
was playing 68 year old Rebecca she
starred at the makeup process by taking
Advil to protect from the inevitable
headache she would endure while her hair
was pinned back we feel you girl there's
no better feeling than removing a
ponytail at the end of the day number 13
Girls Just Want to Have Fun well boys do
too while Tom Holland is no stranger to
women's fashion he was not too happy
with needing to wear a thong under the
Spidey suit this was not optional and
coming in second place for most
uncomfortable part of the suit has to be
Holland drinking water through a straw
protruding out of the suit's eye number
14. washing off your makeup after a long
day is no joke ER washing Margot
Robbie's makeup off during Suicide Squad
was a pain in the the little monster
they set up a pop-up tent inside an
abandoned building stood her in a kiddie
pool and sprayed her down with Hudson
sprayers we were relieved to find out a
Hudson sprayer was not a fire hose but
it still sounds uncomfortable no number
15. that's not the way menthol's
supposed to be used Joe Kiri was a gooey
snotty-nosed mess during the filming of
stranger things in the scene where his
character was getting beat up he had a
sponge stuffed up his nose and Menthol
blown into his eyes
not much acting is really necessary in a
scene where you're actually looking and
feeling like total garbage I was like
all swollen underneath the makeup number
16 it does not get worse than this the
final battle in Twilight had Elizabeth
Reeser who played as May Cullen in a ton
of pain normally snow in the eye isn't
painful but when you're wearing contacts
and that snow is actually made out of
paper it's bound to hurt in a whole new
way her eyelids swelled up from it one
of the worst possible things we can
imagine is paper cuts in the eyes are
your eyes itchy now too let's move on
17. still better than bad breath being
Cinderella seems like a dream come true
until you remember the impossible beauty
standards thrust upon women in Hollywood
there were some news reports that Lily
James's waist had been digitally shrunk
down in her ball gown but nope Lily was
squeezed into a very tiny corset she
could didn't eat in costume and so was
just chugging back liquids because it's
all she could digest and she had to take
frequent breaks while they filmed dance
scenes because she found herself
breathless and not because any Prince
was sweeping her off her feet and her
shoes they were made of real Swarovski
Crystals they were incredibly painful
and the actor couldn't even get them on
it doesn't fit but because it's made as
Frosty Crystal number 18. trust us
complaining doesn't get you anywhere
Barry Keon was a big complainer about
the three layers to his costume
especially when it came to the heat take
three layers to it I complained every
day about it while boiling alive in a
superhero suit isn't anything new for
actors we can definitely say we
empathize with him all the same it's
quite hard to move in number 19. we're
not talking about bearded dragons did
you hear about the real flaming beard
that was used in Pirates of the
Caribbean here comes the smolder actor
Vince was was burned other people were
burned and the beard actually caught on
fire seriously this one should have just
been done with CGI number 20 for what
was supposed to be a floating scene she
sure was weighed down a lot she blows up
like a balloon and floats away and it's
a lot easier to say that than it is to
do it Pam Ferris blowing up like a
balloon as ant Marge in Harry Potter
wasn't CGI her inflatable suit had three
stages of Prosthetics and weighed about
50 pounds it contained special pumps
degassing Chambers for inflating and
deflating the suit and expandable rubber
bladders seriously they couldn't find
better names for this stuff the crazy
part is the suit caused her to faint
while they were filming the scene kind
of enjoyed wallowing in it it was
helpful
um sort of self-inflicted pain Disney
characters look effortlessly ethereal
but working 16-hour days in tight
costumes with thick Prosthetics isn't
exactly a magical experience behind the
scenes there were fake faces complicated
contacts and some of the most
restrictive corsets in the world you
might see these live action scenes
differently once you know how these
actors really felt after being poked and
prodded into fairy tale Perfection once
you put those things on you feel like
Cruella Deville Emma Stone had 47 looks
to wear in the upcoming Cruella movie
she even had to let makeup artists
graffiti her face but the most
challenging outfits for Emma were those
which had super long trains particularly
the garbage truck dress which had a
train that was 40 feet long it's like
things you only ever imagined and didn't
think you would actually put on your
body and carry behind you on a garbage
truck she couldn't even move with it on
so the train had to be added to the
Dress after Emma climbed on the back of
the truck a scene we'll have to wait to
see in the movie if we want to know how
well she actually pulled it off for
Cruella Emma Stone did a lot of climbing
while wearing epic dresses this look
with an incredibly long red train had to
be worn while the actress climbed on top
of a car pulling the skirt around the
car without it getting caught was the
hardest part and not letting the weight
of the dress pull her to the ground
co-star Emma Thompson gave her props for
her skill in maneuvering the heavy dress
saying she had to put it around the car
about a million times because it was so
hard to get right every single part is
so beautifully played to become the
Beast Dan Stevens had to walk around on
stilts and wear a 40-pound prosthetic
muscle suit covered with visual effects
indicators that tracked his every
movement he compared the stilts to
wearing 10 inch high heels it's an
ordeal for my calf muscles alone
thankfully he wore a cooling unit under
his suit that could be plugged in
between takes so he didn't overheat what
if regrettably large hit you have
I should very much like to have it it
wasn't just CGI that made the red
Queen's head huge in Alice in Wonderland
Helena Bonham Carter also had a
prosthetic forehead applied to make her
head seem larger and push back her
hairline the three pound wig on top of
her head didn't make things any more
comfortable and costume designer Colleen
Atwood outfitted her with an Elizabethan
dress with a high collar the actress's
head was then digitally enhanced to
appear three times its normal size on
film but that meant Helena had to be
really careful about not bringing her
hands anywhere near her head while
acting so they wouldn't interfere with
the special effects they reminded me of
a so often that my I was much wider than
I thought ever find yourself wishing you
had a pair of Cinderella's glass
slippers well you should count yourself
lucky that you don't while the original
plan was to have Lily James wear the
slippers it turns out they were much too
painful and she couldn't even get them
on it doesn't fit because it's made as
Frosty Crystal real ones were designed
for the film but the slippers we see the
princess actually wear are completely
CGI
the fate of glass
yes turning Angelina Jolie into
Maleficent was a daunting task every day
it took three hours to apply her
Prosthetics and later remove her
Prosthetics and she had to wear them for
16 hours a day Jolie insisted on their
use herself they included teeth nose ear
and cheek pieces once the horns go on
you start to
mind you the first few days you knock
your head on everything and while
wearing them wasn't the most comfortable
thing in the world having them applied
and then removed was by far the most
painful part of the process as it
involved a lot of poking and prodding
the actress's skin turning Johnny Depp
into the Mad Hatter involved some
complicated contacts and crooked teeth
he was transformed by makeup artist
Valley O'Reilly and hair stylist Terry
beliel the orange wig and clown-like
makeup was a daunting task but what was
most uncomfortable were these kooky
contacts the actor wore for all his
scenes but Depp knew exactly what he was
signing up for since the Mad Hatter's
look was based on watercolors by the
actor and director Tim Burton oh great
one who summons me
terrible one who commands me
creating the genie for Aladdin meant
putting Will Smith in a motion capture
suit the real uncomfortable part of this
costume wasn't that it was too stiff or
restrictive it was that it was thin and
Skin Tight not leaving much to the
imagination it was done this way so they
could catch the actor's angles and
movements perfectly since the genie
isn't technically wearing clothes that
is actually me it's a 100 CGI character
Emma Watson loved Belle's yellow ball
gown but it was actually a deceivingly
thick dress to wear it was made from
multiple layers of satin organza to add
a modern look to the Gown
2160 Swarovski Crystals were added to
the top layer of the dress multiple
copies of the dress were created for
these scenes taking over 12 000 hours to
make in total I had the big dress on he
had the ridiculous Beast thing you know
we were like it was very bonding to
accommodate Aladdin's running along
rooftops the design team traded pointy
toe slippers for sturdier custom
designed ankle boots but not every one
of his outfits was made for Comfort
Aladdin eventually has his Prince Ally
makeover and has to wear copious layers
of Ivory and gold including a long cape
and an oversized turban embellished with
ostrich feathers it was sweltering in
the heat so performing in this costume
was the least fun part of filming no
matter how good he looked did you know
that acrobatic performers have to wear
tight corsets despite all their flips
and tricks actress Eva Green found that
out the hard way when she performed many
of her own aerial stunts in dumbo she
had to trade her comfortable and
flexible training outfit for a circus
outfit that was much more restrictive
and had many decorative pieces for her
to be aware of as well as a perfectly
quaffed wig Colleen Atwood designed the
costumes as circus performer accurate as
possible which meant a pretty tight
stiff bodice and I was so scared of of
heights it was real phobia
and I are really panicked at the
beginning Annie brunette who bleaches
their hair will know it is not easy but
for Alice in Wonderland actress Mia
vasakowska insisted on having her hair
really bleached to the perfect blonde
instead of just wearing a wig she went
through endless hair dyeing sessions and
touch-ups during filming and since her
hair is pinned straight the waves had to
be touched up between almost every take
the fairy Godmother's dress in
Cinderella was the biggest dress created
for the movie with Incredible volume
that actress Helena Bonham Carter was
basically swimming in so the dress was a
piece of architecture Sandy Powell
spared no effort designing the costume
this costume is not like the rest
actually underneath here is a crinoline
cage which actually gives it the
silhouette there are LED lights and 10
000 Swarovski Crystals hooked up to it
with tiny fine wires so Helena had to be
incredibly careful with it especially
while running in some of her scenes when
it came to making Maleficent fly a
pretty simple costume Edition ended up
being one of the most challenging things
for Angelina Jolie to wear and perform
in the wings were CGI but Jolie actually
had to wear little stumps on her back so
they could digitally add the wings later
this proved a challenge because she had
to always be sure to move as if she had
huge Wings protruding from her back the
most painful part of getting these Wings
just right was the fork-like rig she and
other flying characters had to be hooked
up to when filming their flight scenes
mulan's costume designer Bina degler
knew exactly how she wanted to bring one
of the characters most iconic looks to
life but it wasn't an easy outfit for
actress Leo fa to perform in there are
multiple layers of robe under dress
panels and a sash that all add drama and
flow to the outfit it nearly took four
weeks to embroider and 40 feet of
material it wasn't as light and easy to
move in as it seems so actress Leo fa
was tasked with making movement in the
heavy costume look effortless that's
that might be not every day everyone
could experience creature Actor Ed
Osmond had to wear a very strange suit
to become Dumbo while all we see on
screen is the incredible CGI behind the
scenes he had to wear a green suit and
crutch-like arm extensions he was
walking on all fours for about three
hours per day proving his role in the
movie was one of the hardest to master
becoming Elliot the Dragon for the
live-action Pete's Dragon was another
daunting task that required a huge green
suit motion capture actor Eric signed in
had to wear a massive green wire mesh
head so it would look like the actors
were really interacting with the dragon
sure it was heavy and bulky but the size
also made it super easy to track and
later alter with CGI we were able to
capture exactly what he was seeing and
we were going to be able to put that
back on the screen makeup artist and
designer Denise Kum was responsible for
mulan's incredible matchmaking makeup
but the look was thick and made facial
expressions challenging each stage was
layered with a mix of pigments fashion
makeup and conventional makeup and it
was all literally painted onto mulan's
face while Mulan cuts her hair in the
animated version designing hair for the
live action version was also much
different and involved applying tons of
hair pieces to Leo yuffe's hair Lily
James and the live-action Cinderella
were in the news a lot over reports that
her waist had been digitally shrunk in
her ball gown but in reality it was just
a very tight and painful corset
is very hard to breathe it took 20
minutes to get Lily in and then out of
the dress and Corset which took 20
people to make and featured 10 000
Swarovski Crystals and three miles of
hems Princess Jasmine has more than 10
outfit changes during the film the most
painful dress Naomi Scott had to wear
was this Royal pink number the bodice
was tight and restrictive and it was
embellished with heavy gold coins that
the actress had to be careful not to
Rattle too much or catch on anything
while moving around the most challenging
costume for Emily Blunt to wear as Mary
Poppins was this dress while they look
like they have Ruffles and fabric
details it's all painted on to blend in
with the animation of the scene which
also affected the way Emily had to wear
the costumes she had to carry them as if
they did have Ruffles and voluminous
skirts and make sure her movements
didn't make the dresses fall flat
turning 2D designs into a 3D dress gone
through three hours of makeup and then
stand in front of the mirror and see
yourself transformed for some acting in
a Harry Potter movie sounds like a dream
come true but when you realize how
incredibly uncomfortable some of the
makeup effects were it might make things
seem a little less appealing from
transforming humans into gringott's
goblins to the hours of makeup to bring
Voldemort to life and even a giant body
double for Hagrid some of the most
iconic Harry Potter makeup
transformations were seriously painful
for the actors Underneath It All had
Prosthetics on before and it's like it
can be tough it can be like hard work
for the second task in the Goblet of
Fire Harry had to eat Gilly weed and
grow gills so he could swim into the
Black Lake which you might assume would
all be done with CGI but nope they
actually did it for real the gills were
made out of silicone and silk so that
they would Billow underwater they had to
be glued onto Daniel Radcliffe's neck so
firmly so that they would stay put
during the long underwater filming
process and also during the harrowing
scene where he had to swim to the
surface carrying two head heavy lifelike
dolls of Ron and Gabrielle Delacour in
the end Daniel said that he was really
proud that he made it through good God
who's that really Robbie Coltrane who
plays Hagrid is tall but not giant tall
in order to transform him into the half
giant Hagrid they gave him risers in his
shoes and patted him with heavy costumes
extra wigs and Prosthetics to make him
appear larger but they also brought in a
six foot four body double for wide shots
who had to wear some massive padding and
a prosthetic animatronic Hagrid head
because the costume was so huge and
heavy they actually attached tubes that
pumped cold water into it so the body
double didn't overheat and pass out the
embarrassment of seeing yourself a
high in front of a lot of people you
don't know in order to transform human
actors into gringott's Goblins the
makeup team started their work at 4am
they created molds of each actor's face
and created a combination of rubber
masks and individual prosthetic parts to
attach one by one the actors also had to
have their hands covered with extensive
makeup and prosthetic pieces long fake
fingernails and Dentures to finish off
the look each goblin took four hours to
get ready and they even wore contact
lenses that obscured their Vision so
much that they needed chaperones to help
get them around the set on this one
we're doing 45 full prosthetic makeups
British actor Warwick Davis not only
played Professor Flitwick the first
goblin bank teller but also grip hook in
the Harry Potter series very unusual
to make sure he was unrecognizable from
one character to the next it took hours
and hours in the makeup chair first they
created a cast of his face which
involved sitting under layers of
silicone and plaster for hours and only
his nose holes free to breathe once the
prosthetic pieces for grip hook were
applied Warwick said he had to relearn
how to use his face underneath all those
extra layers and totally adjust his
voice to speak through the false teeth
hello ready for the office in order to
make the actor who played Dumbledore's
brother aberforth look as much like
Michael gambin as possible they used a
lot of makeup and extensive wigs the
makeup crew added silicone to his
forehead and face to push back his
hairline applied prosthetic bags under
his eyes completely changed his eyebrows
and of course added his long hair and
beard to finish off the look it was
quite interesting because in a way we
were working on a blank canvas even
though you might think it was CGI the
scene in which Harry accidentally blows
up his aunt Marge was all done in camera
it took 20 people to build and apply the
inflatable suit to Pam Ferris the
actress who played Aunt Marge and
included pumps degassing Chambers and
inflatable bladders they even created a
balloon shaped and painted like her face
attached it to her body and pumped it
full of air to give the effect of her
face inflating
to film Professor Loop in turning into a
werewolf they created each step of the
transformation on the actor David thulis
with prosthetic makeup before adding CGI
in post the makeup team wanted to avoid
the cliche werewolf transformation so
they focused on changing his eyes and
bringing out the two huge scars across
his face with makeup and silicone each
step of the transformation took six
hours to complete and they actually
built fake moving body parts that were
attached to David so they could capture
as much as possible in camera
that turned out not to be practical much
to my relief because it looked really
very uncomfortable to do that when it
came to Peter Pettigrew the makeup team
tried hard to connect the human version
of Pettigrew to scabbers the rat through
his hair skin texture and hands the
actor sat for hours in the makeup chair
as they added the gray balding wig
Browning teeth dirty pointy nails and
skin texture until he was almost
entirely covered in makeup and itchy
fake hair
horrible profession
but I think you should be an actor even
though we might not realize it Lucius
Malfoy undergoes a serious change over
the course of the Harry Potter movies
the actor said he went from a simple
natural look and wig application to a
lot more time in the makeup trailer they
added prosthetic bags under his eyes and
very heavy pale makeup to make him look
as tired and unhealthy as the character
needed to be
become a shadow of his former self if
poly juice potion were a real thing it
would be much easier than what Brendan
Gleason went through to become Mad Eye
Moody they spent hours adding an entire
layer of skin over his real face to
build the eye and its holder into in
order to make it look like it was
embedded in his face they covered his
real eye in tape and added the bulging
glass eye over it so for the entire
shoot he could only see out of one eye
the magical eye was radio controlled by
a crew member who made it swivel around
but sometimes it would actually pop out
sponge the transfers onto my scalp and
face seeing Voldemort for the first time
was a huge undertaking because of how
enormous the fans expectations were for
that exact moment in order to transform
the handsome Rafe finds into the dark
lord they used a combination of makeup
and Prosthetics the process took hours
but luckily he only had to do the full
transformation about 60 to 70 times
throughout the whole series and about 50
of those times were for the last two
movies Rafe still wanted to be able to
act under it all so they covered his
eyebrows reshaped his eyes added long
creepy fingernails and false teeth but
the transformation wasn't complete until
they removed his nose using CGI sort of
slightly translucent
vein like quality we all remember the
scene where Harry breaks his arm playing
quidditch and gilderoy Lockhart comes
along to fix it but ends up removing all
the bones instead well that wobbly
boneless arm wasn't CGI at all but was
actually a prosthetic that they actually
attached to the real Daniel Radcliffe
and guess what he still has it along
with a few pairs of Potter glasses
Daniel said that he has that creepy fake
arm sitting in his attic all these years
later
um I thought I don't seek them out when
creating Professor trelawny Emma
Thompson had the idea that since she is
always looking into the future the
Divination teacher can't really see
where she is in the present so they came
up with her famous coke bottle glasses
while they were perfect for making her
eyes look very funny and large they were
actually quite uncomfortable as they
magnified everything around her you must
look beyond for the enormous battle at
Hogwarts the makeup team worked overtime
to apply fake blood and wounds to the
literally hundreds of actors and
background performers playing the
students and members of Dumbledore's
Army the actors especially Matthew Lewis
who played Neville Longbottom had to
wear itchy uncomfortable fake blood and
silicone prosthetic wounds for days on
end during filming which got very
tiresome in the end which was great to
start with you know blood and cuts and
bruises and it takes like two hours to
transform the very young very famous
actors into older versions of themselves
it required lots of Prosthetics and
makeup but not too much according to the
crew the first old age test made Ron
look about 75 years old and seriously
unhealthy eventually they found a good
balance did it work well that's for you
to decide
oh
everyone knows actors and actresses deal
with the stress of hair and makeup on
set but did you ever think that their
on-screen makeup and Prosthetics might
be taking a toll on them anyone who
wears makeup knows just how annoying
putting it on and taking it all off
again can be but wait till you see the
painstaking process that these 15 actors
were put through in their makeup
transformations to make you feel truly
grateful for your own makeup routine
stick around to see how these actors and
actresses dealt with these sticky
makeovers
after 20 different makeup tests to find
the perfect shade of blue for Jennifer
Lawrence's character Mystique the
process of completing this actress's
makeup for the X-Men film was already
proving to be challenging can you
believe it took six girls seven hours to
fully paint the actress's body which
every woman knows as our dream come true
in order to keep ourselves up an atom
during the application process Lawrence
would either stand or work out on a
bicycle to keep her blood pumping Not
only was Lawrence's full blue bodysuit
of makeup arduous to get on but it was
painful to keep on as the actress
reported the blue paint to be irritating
to her skin causing boils and blisters
to her complexion apparently they've
simplified the bluing of you turns out
they never had to do eight hours of
full-blown body paint ever
as much as the Prosthetics used on Anya
chalatra may have added to her role on
the set of The Witcher the very same
Prosthetics that enhanced her acting
abilities also caused her physical harm
and the costume and the blood and
sweat after being fitted with a
hunchback to make her character that
much more believable the star fell
victim to a pulled nerve causing her
lots of pain the thickness of her
costume caused even more sweaty
discomfort that the actress had to deal
with during her time on set she even
said I have a trapped nerve in my back
that I had to get massaged out after
playing her for so long it was very
uncomfortable
not much for this Beast
from a full-blown headcast to hours of
makeup it's no wonder Anne Hathaway
needed to vent about her makeup
experience for the witch's movie she
took to Instagram and called her makeup
look her resting witch face after
sitting through having her whole head
enveloped in whatever that is in order
to mold her facial Prosthetics Hathaway
must have needed to take a well-deserved
breather from her makeup process if you
notice you know in the length of the
video because it's a time lapse I got
stuck
after insisting upon the use of
Prosthetics herself Angelina Jolie was
fitted with cheek nose ear and teeth
Prosthetics to bring her character a
Maleficent to life Angelina stated in an
interview we didn't want her to be
somebody that when you were staring at
her during a real dramatic scene that
you were distracted by her makeup so it
had to be extreme but her soul had to
come out despite its Simplicity this
makeup look took a full three hours to
apply and one hour to take off every day
and Jolie wore it for 16 hours at a time
ouch and it was like um living out some
childhood fantasy
you know that being in such intense
makeup for his role as Vision was in no
way comfortable as Paul Bettany is seen
ripping off his full face makeup which
might be the most painful part of the
process this makeup look takes the actor
only an hour and a half of application
time not too shabby compared to some of
the other actors on this list the most
uncomfortable part of betani's
prosthetic setup is his lack of hearing
with makeup artists having to make
adjustments to his Prosthetics in order
for him to be able to hear at all and I
didn't think for a minute what that was
actually gonna mean to me physically
Ryan Reynolds painful makeup application
for his character Deadpool was truly
grueling because of the time that went
into the look Reynolds was a good sport
maybe even too good of a sport as he
pranked his makeup artist by ripping off
his facial Prosthetics after hours of
application
I'm not gonna do it right you know
there's no point in doing it at all
during John race Davy's startling
transformation into Gimli the actor had
to face terrible makeup processes which
left him barely able to see and made his
skin break out in an allergic reaction
the Lord of the Rings actor had to work
on Alternate days in order to give his
skin a break from the harsh makeup
process you can't really see my brows
moving all the rest of it
in order to transform lead actor Jacob
Tremblay into a boy with the genetic
disorder Treacher Collins syndrome
makeup artist needed full body
Prosthetics to make it work the makeup
itself took an hour and a half of
painfully meticulous application and
suited Jacob up in a full head of
Prosthetics no way is it comfortable
wearing a fake face and head for nine
whole hours of shooting it was like
there was a nice cozy warm cocoon around
your head Game of Thrones is known for
its creative and interesting character
design Kai Alexander's role as Leaf was
no exception to this imaginative
creativity the most painful thing about
this makeover process was definitely its
run time as Kai had to sit for nearly 10
hours to get this makeup on and ready
for the spotlight
um I sat in a chair for 10 hours top to
bottom including the wig
even makeup artist David White calls
nebula's makeup look the most complex
and interesting of any of the characters
in Guardians of the Galaxy it was very
challenging especially on a female I had
to be sexy and uh kind of comic book but
believable this makeup look was so
intense it took five hours of
application and even required Karen to
shave her head she knew this going into
the audition process but didn't really
get a chance to process the bald headed
change until she got the role I don't
know if dedication to a makeup look gets
more uncomfortable than that and I might
have done something a little bit crazy
yeah
this not very well-known actress has had
an even less well-known transformation
into pepper from American Horror Story
asylum the makeup look that transformed
her into pepper takes about three hours
and two makeup artists including
blinding her in one eye with a contact
lens and setting her up with a pair of
fake teeth imagine sitting in makeup for
three hours and then having to walk
around half blind afterwards how
uncomfortable
hi
the most uncomfortable part of
Vladimir's transformation into the night
King in the Game of Thrones series has
to be the six and a half you heard me
six and a half hours of sitting in the
makeup chair then once in full night
King Garb the actor had to remember not
to Blink while in character the combo of
painstaking makeup application and these
intense stage directions definitely made
for an uncomfortable experience on the
Game of Thrones set it looks like easy
but
definitely it's not so easy
another leading woman who had to deal
with the absolute torture of full body
makeup application is Zoe Saldana in her
role as Gamora in Guardians of the
Galaxy just like Jayla she had to deal
with the trials and tribulations of many
color tests to get her to be the perfect
shade of green the Marvel franchise star
revealed just how long it took to apply
all of her makeup over three hours and
with the help of two separate makeup
artists Zoe is quoted saying the whole
coming together of Gamora every morning
that was a little grueling
famous actress Haley Berry played six
different characters in Cloud Atlas so
it's surprising that you may have never
even seen it her makeup transformation
into six different identities was surely
an uncomfortable hassle as the actress
also had to deal with a recently broken
foot on set her makeup artist Jeremy
Woodhead is quoted saying even with all
the discomfort she was going through it
was necessary to the story of each
character that part was thrilling as an
actor and a huge challenge
one of the most well-known makeup movie
jobs in history has also been one of the
most uncomfortable when transforming
into the Grinch Jim Carrey is known for
being irritated by yellow contact lenses
being restrained by his full bodysuit
and needing the help of a torture
specialist to get through the movie
shoot it was when I did the Grinch I was
literally the makeup was like being
buried alive every day you won't believe
how many of these actors didn't have any
CGI used for their MCU character instead
they had hours in a makeup chair which
actor had such intense body makeup and
Prosthetics that they literally had to
sit in a sauna so it could melt off how
about the actor who carried an extra
eight pounds of weight on their head
alone
CGI magic is impressive but these
extraordinary makeup prosthetic and
costume Transformations will blow you
away when it was time to be in the
makeup chair Michael B Jordan spent a
whole two and a half hours every single
day having a whopping 90 individual
Prosthetics glued and sealed on his body
leaving the actor totally exhausted by
the end of it what's worse is that he
was nowhere near the end of his work day
since he still actually had to shoot as
for the removal process well he was
stuck in a sauna to help all the
Prosthetics actually sweat off
there she is in all her glory when Tom
Hiddleston put on his Loki suit he was
carrying around an extra 30 pounds add
the headpiece an extra eight pounds a
whopping 40 extra pounds at all times
this large and heavy helmet covers
hiddleston's ears which also limit how
much he was able to actually hear the
suit itself was extremely hot and sweaty
for the actor and with the helmet well
he was facing an overwhelming Iggy sweat
Fest every single day Hiddleston said
the whole experience was uncomfortable
and left him feeling really
claustrophobic or the first piece locks
you like that the second piece zips up
and launches like that and the third
piece is like the new Captain America is
here but for Wyatt Russell it's been a
long time coming he auditioned for the
role years ago when he was cast as the
new captain he actually asked if he
could wear Chris evans's suit what we
see him in here in the Falcon in the
Winter Soldier though is a new costume
made just for him a hot stiff difficult
and painful costume it it was so bad
that an old shoulder injury of his
actually flared up part of the reason
it's so uncomfortable is because there's
supposed to be a sort of presentational
effect have you ever seen a superhero
with bad posture next time you watch the
show remember that Russell is working
through loads of pain every day there's
something that's easier and something
that's harder she looks good there's no
denying that but at what cost well Tessa
Thompson knows since she was the one
wearing an almost entirely plastic
outfit definitely not comfortable or
breathable despite feeling incredibly
stiff hot and always sweating Thompson
managed to act her way through it if
that weren't Tough Enough she also had
her fair share of wire work discomfort
on top of discomfort my makeup goes on
much faster but it's it's slight glue
they're actually glue transfers that
then they stick to me Dave Bautista
every shoot day is dry
as Drac right think again he also had a
whopping five hours in the makeup chair
every single day getting 18 pieces of
prosthetic attached and makeup done by
five different makeup artists if that
weren't bad enough Bautista had to stand
for the majority of it with his arms
sticking out
how he still had the energy to perform
is a total mystery to us so how does the
sauna fit into all of this
well when he first had the makeup on
rubbing it off was so tough on his body
that it damaged his skin to the point
that he described it looking like
hamburger meat so the best solution was
to put him in a sauna so the makeup
could just melt off coming together of
Gamora every morning that was a little
grueling five hours in the makeup chair
before even starting on set is insane
but for Zoe Saldana it became part of
her daily routine when she was playing
Gamora not only did she have loads of
makeup and some facial Prosthetics put
on she spent plenty of time being
covered in this intense thick green
paste
not a fun time at all Elizabeth Debicki
had a shorter prep time than many of the
other Marvel characters but she still
spent a solid hour and a half with two
makeup artists at work her prep pretty
much involved being painted and allowing
it to dry until she was ready to get
into what was lovingly called the Aisha
Taco AKA this giant metal gold dress
while it looks Regal and elegant the
costume was made almost entirely of
metal making it super heavy for her to
move and work in dibiki described it as
similar to having a child hanging off
your back yeah not a great feeling
Robert Downey Jr has had many costumes
over the years when he played Iron Man
but one thing for sure is that none of
them were enjoyable to wear
the actor said that his experience with
the costumes was so tough at times it
almost led to a personality breakdown
this suit it's no surprise to learn it's
extremely heavy stuffy and hot remember
he doesn't just have to wear it but
perform intensely in it I can't believe
I made a whole movie with this thing
Wyatt Russell may have wanted to wear
Chris evans's suit but it's probably for
the best that he didn't since Evan's
detested wearing his Captain America
suit overall it was super tight and
sweaty we can see how fitted it is here
super tough considering how much he has
to move and so athletically the cap was
confirmed to be the worst part of the
costume not only is it kind of awkward
looking it was also super tight and
uncomfortable and made it really tricky
to hear others lines can you imagine
needing six people to help you get out
of your clothes so you could go to the
washroom if not ask Brie Larson since
this was her reality filming Captain
Marvel in the skin tight superhero get
up getting into this costume itself well
that just took two people in a full half
hour and then there was the tight and
restrictive helmet composed of five
different pieces that all sort of
slotted together on her head Not only
was she stuck wearing the extremely
uncomfortable costume for hours on end
she also had to fly in it painful much
the worst part is when is honestly is
getting an itch because it's so thick
have you ever been on a 15-hour flight
if so you know it is super uncomfortable
and according to Ant-Man himself Paul
Rudd that is exactly what wearing his
costume was like the suit is skin tight
thick and extremely hot especially when
shooting in Atlanta Georgia red admitted
that one of the worst parts of wearing
the suit was when he had an itch that
needed scratching the suit made it
impossible so he resorted to literally
having people on set punch the itchy
spots in hopes of deterring the
discomfort it looks like he could still
enjoy himself through the pain though
Karen Gillen essentially has nebula's
skin glued right onto her see how they
added all the Prosthetics while it looks
smooth enough the process was actually
quite intense and claustrophobic for the
actress the whole transformation usually
took an insane five hours to complete
often giving Dylan a start time of 2 am
These Eyes courtesy of 22 millimeter
wide black contact lenses
definitely adds to the claustrophobic
feeling
by the way there is no CGI used on her
in the Final Cut of the film when I had
that the audition I had no idea how big
the character would be Palm clementiev
had to spend a crazy three hours in the
makeup chair each day she was shooting
to transform into mantis on top of that
clementiev said keeping a straight face
in the makeup chair was super
challenging as well
so how exactly exactly did they
accomplish this exotic look small
Prosthetics at the top of her forehead
acted as marks for her antennae and her
bug-like eyes were courtesy of huge
black contacts it looks cool but she was
left feeling super claustrophobic and
uncomfortable because of them we do this
great uh black war paint it's like a tar
painted across my face Ronan the Accuser
looks incredible on screen but how much
work went into bringing him to life well
Lipe spent countless hours sitting in
the makeup chair being painted a
Periwinkle color having veins painted in
and of course these thick black bits on
his face Pace described it like having
tar on your face which doesn't make the
whole acting thing easy it was so
painful and restrictive his face
couldn't move naturally at all while it
felt so stiff and heavy on top of all
that he had purple contacts and a
headdress
torture much even just to do this is
like two pounds six pounds ten pounds
when Michael chiklas took on the role of
the thing in the first two Fantastic
Four films CGI wasn't quite as advanced
as it is now so he wore a full suit made
out of latex and rubber it took two
hours to get the full costume on
prosthetic teeth included when it came
to performing chicklist struggled with
such a stiff costume that made simple
tasks like sitting or picking up a
bottle of water extremely tough because
whenever he moved the suit would
actually tighten and tense up leaving
him in loads of pain it
the hottest I've ever been typically we
hear about actors having to get in shape
for their Marvel roles but it was a
totally different story for Chris
Hemsworth while he didn't gain weight
for his times fat Thor he did carry
around some extra weight an insane 60 to
70 pounds to be exact oh yeah that's
just how much the Prosthetics weigh
without armor the suit limited how much
he was able to move and was generally
extremely uncomfortable and super hot
and I was like all swollen underneath
the makeup then it was turns out a trip
to Hawkins isn't all sunshine and
daisies both on screen and behind the
scenes stranger things has had their
fair share of goriness and horror over
the past three seasons and while we may
think it looked Epic on screen it's at
the expense of the cast suffering
through just as many hours in the makeup
Department as they do on set it's time
to find out just what would make the
stranger things cast want to trade a day
in prosthetics for a trip to the upside
down instead I've been waiting to make
this King Steve everybody's been telling
me so much about both Billy Hargrove and
daker Montgomery were put through the
ringer in season three just in different
ways with the Mind flare on the loose
and getting mixed up with Billy it
resulted in plenty of wounds wounds that
were all created by the makeup and
special effects Department there was no
CGI or VFX for this character daker
spent hours on end in the makeup chair
before heading to set each day and when
Billy was at his worst daker was
sporting 33 Prosthetics at once 33.
between him and his stunt double the
makeup team had to create and apply 99
Prosthetics in one day he was wearing so
much glue that during one of his lunch
breaks his arm Prosthetics got stuck to
the tablecloth what made things even
worse is Millie Bobby Brown's knee
injury actually caused the filming of
daycare scenes to be pushed up with
barely any notice the makeup department
head Amy L Forsyth said I got a call
during the Hiatus giving me a heads up
about doing the post sauna scene with
Billy on the stairwell getting his
wounds nursed the day after we were to
get back from Hiatus I hadn't even seen
a preview for the sauna fight so I
didn't know how he was getting hurt or
where his wounds might be I gotta warn
you again in your band for Life The
Duffer brothers were super adamant about
including as many practical effects as
they could in stranger things which
means season 1 barely required any
digital visual effects including the
demogorgon the demogorgon was actually
just one big prosthetic suit that was
worn by actor Mark Steger however opting
for practical effects came with some
pretty big challenges for Mark he had to
perform some intense stunts in the suit
that he couldn't properly hear or see in
but he did say that it helped him
remember why he loved film in the later
Seasons The Duffer Brothers eventually
decided to move on to more of a CGI
route let's just say things got a little
too gooey it's crazy this is crazy daker
loved being able to embrace Billy by
adding on his bad boy characteristics
like his tattoo and Scar however it was
at the expense of spending more time in
the makeup chair after a full day of
filming daker would endure another two
hours removing the Prosthetics from his
body including the Prosthetics he needed
to cover his facial hair Shadow he wore
the Prosthetics so much that at one
point he noticed his body hair wasn't
even growing back anymore every day when
you spend like two hours getting them
off like I remember there was a big cut
and Scar right here you can see I've got
no hair on my arm there because it's
just been months and months of Shaving
right in that spot it shouldn't have
looked for me as much as we all love
Steve Harrington now there was a time
where him getting beat up wasn't
something we felt bad about but you
might feel bad for Joe Kiri when you
hear what he had to go through while
wearing these Prosthetics Not only was
Joe sick on the day they shot these
scenes but he had to have Menthol blown
in his eyes to achieve the desired
effects
ouch to be specific Amy shared that his
Prosthetics included a swollen jaw lump
cut split lip and a mixture of cotton
and dried blood she shared her process
on Instagram and even called Joe a
trooper boy ladies I didn't see you
there Will's possession scene took a
major toll on Noah schnapp both mentally
and physically not only did he have to
put himself in a dark place but his
costume consisted of black contacts that
made his eyes burn his costume was also
not designed for the weather although it
may have looked like it was warm on
screen Noah explains it was filmed in
the middle of winter there was just so
much going on the heaters didn't
actually heat up it wasn't really hot it
was actually really cold because it was
winter
the cherry on top of it all was that
Noah was so overworked and tired he woke
up the next day with no voice I was
screaming the whole night and the next
morning I woke up and my voice had
disappeared
movie makeup doesn't always mean gory
wounds and scars sometimes the actors
have a difficult time wearing Foundation
heaps of it Nancy never really found
herself in a situation that led to an
injury but she did spend hours each day
in the makeup chair it may not seem like
it but Natalie Dyer says she wore so
much makeup on set that she began
suffering from acne the only solution
was for her to amp up her skincare game
to prevent it from getting any worse we
asked for forgiveness not permission
what the audience doesn't realize is
that Prosthetics can sometimes minimize
an actor's senses in this intense shower
scene that daker had to film he was so
physically involved that he was actually
injured without even realizing he was
only able to see the scrapes and bruises
that he accumulated on his body after
taking off the Prosthetics he was
wearing just listen to him explain his
experience I was covered head to toe in
cuts and bruises and I took all the skin
off the top of my toes and one of
stranger things goriest scenes had to be
when a mind flayer literally hatches
from 11's leg while the Mind player in
this scene was digitally added in
post-production everything else about
the wound was done using makeup and
Prosthetics Millie had the benefit of
using a prosthetic leg instead of her
own however it was still pretty gross to
work with but not gross enough to stop
her from taking an Instagram selfie with
it it took months of research from the
makeup Department in order to make the
leg and wound look as realistic as
possible and it's safe to say they did a
Duffer brother approved job
do it who knew how versatile lip gloss
could be Billy's flayed look was
achieved by applying layers and layers
of Mac clear lip gloss all in all he had
to wear a layer of lip gloss a layer of
dirt and mud and then another layer of
lip gloss to seal it all together as you
can imagine wearing lip gloss wasn't the
most comfortable experience but daker
said it worked better in the scene that
he wasn't constantly having to be
sprayed with water all day to achieve
the wet look just look how big that lip
gloss jar is one of the things we've
gathered from going behind the scenes of
stranger things is that Millie Bobby
Brown gives her all into her character
11. no matter the circumstances
oh
filming her scenes in the void shook her
to her core literally her wardrobe was
not cut out for how cold it was on set
that day especially because she was
constantly working with water The
Stranger Things art director said the
one thing you are missing is that it was
freezing cold on stage that day we shot
this and Millie was a real trooper
splashing around in the cold water sfx
tried to heat it but it was too shallow
to retain any heat
afraid you don't
get him right here when you think about
who The Duffer brothers were inspired by
Steven Spielberg Stephen King and John
Carpenter it's no surprise they went
down the Practical effects route even if
it was uncomfortable for The Stranger
Things cast at times in addition to all
the Prosthetics and makeup they even
used practical effects to create a lot
of The Upside Down set and brutal battle
scenes like Bob's demise did we mention
that Will's body double was so
realistically made by the makeup
Department that they were able to pull
off the ultimate prank on Noah schnapp's
mom the question is what's worse wearing
Prosthetics and makeup or fighting
demogorgons after hearing about how
Barb's actress Shannon Purser had to eat
baby food for her pool scene and Bob's
actor Sean Aston had to continuously put
fake blood in his mouth we're going with
demogorgons do you need some help
I could do her hair whose hair
extensions were so hated the actor
actually ripped them out of their head
on set
we never would have thought the wigs
costumes and Prosthetics used in the
Twilight franchise could be so painful
but actors on set would say otherwise
Anna Kendrick once described it as a
nightmare which actor could barely see
with painful contacts in their eyes
let's have a look
nothing in Twilight is easy the legs
Bella had after breaking her spine in
the Twilight Saga were gone looking
Prosthetics made for Stuart to wear
while filming a prop table was built so
Stewart's real legs could be hidden away
underneath under the table the actress's
legs were in sweatpants
hot and extremely stiff from being stuck
still for so long since she had to do
all her performing from the waist up
even getting in and out of the
contraption was a hassle and Stewart
needed to have extra hands to help her
maneuver the tricky set piece looking
down at you know really flimsy legs is
strange throughout Breaking Dawn Part 1
Bella's body underwent some serious
changes and to help bring the looks to
life a combo of CGI and Prosthetics
reused the Prosthetics added to her face
to make her ears look bigger and eyes
sunken in emphasizing how thin she was
took a grueling three hours to apply
before filming Stewart had to deal with
a lot of extra weight and discomfort
while wearing the as the actress called
it inhumanely large stomach prosthetic
she was totally shocked when she saw
just how big the belly prosthetic was
too weird for the Twilight movies
Pattinson sported his vampire look with
loads of makeup to make him look pale
and light-colored contacts as well those
contact lenses drove Pattinson crazy he
wore them for three consecutive months
and claimed his eyes never got used to
it in fact he said it felt like he had
sand in his eyes the entire time even
getting them into his eyes was a
terrible experience
Pattinson used to have to go through 20
minutes doing each eye and from the very
start they just fold in his eyes anyway
Pat and sublims the lenses for making it
difficult for him to perform and express
emotion since the actor said his vision
was so impeded he could only really see
two orange blobs
did you get contacts
no Kristen Stewart was one of the many
actors who had to wear contact lenses
for her role in filming the Twilight
movies
Stewart didn't have a choice in the
matter but from day one she was looking
forward to the day that she got to say
goodbye to them
sort noted the yellow contacts as the
absolute worst one since they severely
limited the ability to see and made her
feel almost claustrophobic
fine it's no secret that Robert
Pattinson hated the orange wig he had to
wear while doing reshoots of Breaking
Dawn Part 2. the so-called Frankenstein
wig was the result of six different
pieces combined however this isn't the
first time the actor dealt with an
irritating hairpiece when Pattinson
first booked the role the plan was
actually to have him in hair extensions
to bring the Timeless look of Edward to
life Pattinson was not a fan of the idea
at all and one day when he was wearing
them he literally ripped them out of his
hair on set after that the Shaggy
vampire look was born
your skin is
pale white and ice cold
it wasn't just contact lenses that were
a nuisance for Stuart to wear
also had to deal with
blue hair extensions
the actress didn't
fit them at all but had to endure them
to bring the perfect look to screen
in an interview once the actress said
she described that time in her life
simply as really uncomfortable hair
extensions
that is saying a lot yeah I guess
Taylor Lautner had to wear an extremely
long black wig which he was very excited
to get to shed lotner said the wig was
so uncomfortable because it was itchy
hot and just overhaul annoying even the
look of it bothered the actor and he
said he didn't recognize himself when he
had it on the wig turned out to be an
inconvenience for a lot of people going
so far as to ruin shots regularly
the hair was so long and unruly it often
wound up blowing into Lautner's face
one seen a new moon was really dampened
by the wig when he was meant to kiss
Bella his hair blew right into his mouth
and got caught leaving him to spit out
his hair right before kissing her the
last day they had to use the wig Lawton
ripped it off and the entire crew
celebrated since it had been such an
annoyance for everyone after filming the
actor turned down the offer to keep the
wig but has since confessed he wishes
he'd held on to it
in order to achieve Nikki Reed's blonde
hair for the films the actress had to
undergo an intense 36 hours of dying her
hair blonde followed by bleaching
treatments every other day all this
painful treatment destroyed her hair to
the point that it actually started
falling out Reed had to stop the intense
dying treatment so thankfully she got to
switch to a wig for the rest of the Saga
that was all that thing was away she's
been wearing a wig ever since new moon
among the many Twilight actors who had
to wear contacts was Elizabeth Reeser as
Esme Cullen the actress called them
Beyond annoying as well as excruciating
the final battle was one of the most
painful scenes for the actor to endure
all the snow falling which was actually
tiny Bits of Paper started getting
caught inside her eyelids causing them
to swell up a lot of regrets the August
wedding
well let's just say it didn't feel
anything like the warm summer month when
they were filming the scene the actors
struggled to get through filming as they
shivered in their summer formal wear
tween takes all the performers huddled
together cuddling under blankets and
parkas just trying to keep warm Anna
Kendrick was only on set a few times but
she didn't Escape filming in chilly
weather the actress described the
experience as absolutely miserable
I'm just kidding I'm just kidding when
Edward and Bella had their prom it
wasn't actually the warm weather most
people get to have the actors were
freezing cold wearing only Formal Wear
while filming and were quickly covered
with parkas and blankets as soon as the
cameras stopped see you're dancing
he may have been working out intensely
and sticking to a strict diet but he
still didn't look the part the actor
ended up needing to wear heel lifts
inside his shoes so he looked taller
than Christian Stewart for me Kristen
has been absolutely amazing to work with
in a deleted scene from Eclipse Bella
and Jacob were seen growing old together
both actors had a lot of Prosthetics and
aging makeup applied Which is far from a
comfortable experience what made it
worse is that afterwards the team saw
the results of the Prosthetics and they
decided it looked too awkward to be
convincing so the whole process turned
out to be for nothing
[Music]
let's take a moment to acknowledge
Christian Stewart's incredibly awkward
wig and Breaking Dawn her hair was cut
to be a much shorter and edgier style
after filming The Runaways so the hair
Department provided her with a wig to
suit the character however no one
noticed until much after the fact that
the wig looked very strange and
mismatched from Stuart and the film in
general
it was memorable but definitely not for
the right reasons
really I'm not I'm
fine don't say you're fine
when Lautner was playing his wolf self
he really stepped into the role but was
a lot less furry than we'd expect
instead of having a double step in and
take over for the scene that was going
to have CGI added anyway lotner himself
went into full wolf mode and even bent
his head down for Bella to Pat this was
all while Lautner was in a very awkward
tight full body head included gray
leotard definitely not nearly as
intimidating as what we saw in the film
some of you are gonna get hurt
it's no surprise that in these movies
filled with vampires and werewolves
there would be some uncomfortable
costumes but who knew one franchise
could have so many painful wigs it's a
little like thing I pull out and then I
put a squeezy tube down into my mouth
and then I can drink from a bottle just
how uncomfortable can wearing a
Spider-Man suit be every Spider-Man film
has boasted an extremely vibrant
collection of characters equipped with
some state-of-the-art costumes and
makeup from those tight Spidey suits to
those gruesome villainous Prosthetics
the stars of the Spider-Man movies had
to get quite uncomfortable when
portraying their on-screen personas I
was just like swinging about in this
super creepy way and like trying to
trying to talk to Peter who wouldn't
want to suit up as Spider-Man it was our
childhood dream to put on the iconic red
and blue suit and that was no different
for star Tom Holland I feel like my
whole life had been leading up to me
trying on this suit despite the
excitement wearing the suit on set did
come with some setbacks in fact Poland
believes that he has the hardest suit to
wear out of anyone in the Marvel
Universe whenever Holland has the
classic suit on he's covered head to toe
in Lycra with no skin showing I can't
even use my phone and I'm 23 like I use
my phone a lot in fact Poland isn't even
able to scratch an itch on his face in
the costume it's just one of the costs
of being Spider-Man it looks amazing it
feels terrible the costume designers
behind the Mysterio suit wanted to make
sure that it was as practical as
possible since the bulky costume wasn't
particularly the most comfortable fit
the producers assumed that Gyllenhaal
wouldn't want to be wearing the
villain's threads in too many scenes you
know it's like wearing a ball gown like
grab your back you're all of a sudden
choked by this right though Gyllenhaal
was more than willing and
a little excited to Bear through the
discomfort and wear the Mysterio costume
whenever he would see fit so not only is
this costume practical but he wears it
everywhere it makes sense to wear it so
we think this looks amazing took a
little bit of time to put on but once it
was on yeah it made me feel pretty
strong it wasn't just Alfred Molina who
took on the Persona of Doc Ock director
Sam Raimi wanted the villain's trademark
claws to actually be practical effects
which led to puppeteers acting around
Molina to make his robotic tentacles
look more alive Molina needed to do
rehearsals in costumes so he could get
accustomed to moving around in the
complicated suit people understand how
much the actors are doing because you
think oh it's all magical CGI stuff
Topher Grace had to undergo a ruling
makeup process to become the iconic
Spider-Man villain venom for the third
film in the original trilogy I had four
hours of prosthetic makeup every morning
when I was Venom and just getting on the
suit takes about 45 minutes before that
so I had to get there at three or
something grace also had to go through
an extensive workout routine to gain
around 20 pounds for the roll in order
for Dane Dehan to become the grotesque
and slimy Green Goblin the makeup took
over three hours initial designs for the
gross looking villain CAD Dahan taking
on an even Greener look as the iconic
Spider-Man villain but the makeup
Department decided to go for a look that
felt more slightly Human Than full-on
Goblin that's how I started out like you
know playing pretend and dressing up as
superheroes Dane dahan's Goblin suit
weighed 50
where Dahan
with Goblin get up was over a hundred
degrees Fahrenheit and because of the
extreme conditions Dahan lost seven
pounds in just two days now that's
impressive
Jamie Foxx had the distinct advantage of
having two distinctive Styles as Max
Dillon AKA Electro in The Amazing
Spider-Man 2 but it was his villain's
nerdy Alter Ego that was internally
painful for typically sleek and smooth
fox fox dubbed his hair on set as the
first black comb over and he also
sported a gap in his teeth when I was
Max on the streets girls are like look
at Jamie Fox a fat hair oh my God
something is off with him at the same
time Fox was at least somewhat relieved
that he wouldn't be as bombarded with
attention since he figured there'd be
plenty of people who wouldn't recognize
him Honestly though most people would be
able to recognize Jamie Foxx no matter
the makeup hey yo tell everybody
Electro's in town the makeup Department
behind Jamie Foxx's Electro look had to
get very experimental in order to
prevent inhibiting Fox's performance as
the blue-skinned villain very thin
pieces of silicone were applied all over
Fox's body in order for the look to be
much much more believable on top of the
silicone Fox had to wear a glowing blue
contact lenses it was a great choice to
be in this film and I'm happy and
fortunate that they that they chose me
while Reese defends full lizard form was
mostly CGI there still was plenty of
makeup work to be done for the
transitioning stages of the villain
ifans would spend up to seven to eight
hours in the makeup chair to complete
his green scaly look after seven hours
in a chair with not enough cigarettes I
was kind of in the right mental state to
play a man who was about to transform
into a nine-foot lizard with a dangerous
tail the Prosthetics caused a lot of
chafing on ifan's body which led him to
walking around like a cowboy for several
days after filming after all there has
to be some side effects from becoming
the lizard Marvel was extremely strict
about what Holland was supposed to wear
underneath his costume during Holland's
first day on set he was given thongs by
the crew as the only thing he could wear
under the Spider-Man costume I had
serious misgivings would my ever be the
same again but I had to get used to it
I have to wear essentially pajamas
Michael Keaton's vulture suit stands out
and how it combines the classic Marvel
style with something a bit more grounded
I can't tell you there are hundreds
maybe of little screws literally that
special wrenches made to put the boots
in a certain way a costume this
intricate took quite some time to fully
equip on Heaton I don't know what my
favorite costume was because it's like
what 7 30. I'm barely awake I barely
know where I am Andrew Garfield wasn't
necessarily thrilled the first time he
put on his Spider-Man suit the suit he
wore was made of a material that was
designed to make you irritated on top of
that Garfield's suit was skin tight
which led to more of his body being
visible to the public than we would have
preferred one of the first nights we
were out on location in downtown L.A we
were in a parking structure I knew there
were Paparazzi taking terrible
unflattering shots of my you know
everything it was an acting exercise it
was just a lot to uh to hold I I
struggled to hold it all I kind of
rejected it a lot rules were so strict
that Holland claimed that even simply
drinking water in the Spidey suit was
dangerous this led to Holland and the
costume designers having to brainstorm
ways to adapt as obviously Holland would
need some fluids while filming in the
heat oh it is I can kind of get it I've
had a KitKat in the suit now the left
eye on the Spidey costume would have a
squeezy tube attached that Holland would
have to pull out and put into his mouth
so he could get a drink of water how
refreshing I loved in Spider-Man
particularly playing the double role
Willem Dafoe is known for his very
distinguishable jawline so when playing
Norman
first Sam Rainey Spiderman Man movie he
needed to look more like how the
billionaire character looked in the
comics Defoe was given Dental
Prosthetics to make his teeth look
straighter as the main villain though
the Prosthetics were removed whenever
his character would look at himself in
the mirror and they were really fun to
do while Willem Dafoe surprisingly did
not need much prosthetic work done the
acclaimed thespians still had some
discomfort about the Green Goblins
technologically advanced costume Defoe
called his experience in costume severe
though he still had a great time on set
whenever Tom Holland put on that
Spider-Man suit he knew there was no
going back for him in many ways like
having to wait to go to the bathroom an
accident is not an option that suit is
so expensive they'll be so upset with me
in fact Holland would have to plan going
to take a bathroom break 45 minutes in
advance hopefully there were no
accidents while filming Tobey Maguire
wore the iconic red and blue Spider-Man
suit over the course of three films just
because he had a longer tenure as the
character than someone like Andrew
Garfield that didn't make the suit any
more comfortable in fact the black
symbiote suit that McGuire wore in the
third film proved to be the most
uncomfortable suit of them all it can
ride up in the crotch a little bit it's
not really the outerwear of the suit
it's the inner bit that rides up well at
least it wasn't Flash Thompson giving
the wedgies this time Toby Maguire holds
the title of being the first actor to
portray Spider-Man on the big screen and
with that the costume designers were
still trying to work through crafting
the perfect Spider-Man costume in order
to get the costume right the designers
had to do a full body cast of McGuire
which wasn't the most fun experience for
the actor I had to stand there for a
couple of hours and then the stuff
sticking to the hair on my body and they
ripped it off and it was extremely
painful Maguire even initially had a
hard time acting with the Spider-Man
mask on though he was able to get used
to it quite quickly while Andrew
Garfield's Comics accurate Spider-Man
suit may have been a fan favorite in The
Amazing Spider-Man 2. it was far from
comfortable for Garfield to wear it was
a very specific experience and I imagine
it'll be different every time Garfield
blamed his British reverse on the reason
why he was uncomfortable in the costume
spandex does not suit the British you
are pretty much naked so you have to
trust what you have is enough Paul
giamatti's Rhino suit required plenty of
CGI but that didn't prevent his onset
appearance from being an uncomfortable
one in fact giamatti's costume while
filming required him to be attached to a
large metal-like structure some of which
he'd wear with backpack straps there's
clearly a lot that goes into making
these Spider-Man characters look as good
as they do from hours-long makeup
applications to extravagant Prosthetics
and uncomfortable costumes